halo infinite has cheaters progression
woes balancing issues and campaign leaks
let's talk about it
if you didn't know halo infinite's
multiplayer beta is out now and even
though it's being received well by fans
it isn't completely without its issues
players have taken to social media to
report instances of cheating and hacking
in halo infinite and the anti-cheat
police department twitter account found
more than a dozen stores selling cheats
for the game this problem seems to be
more widespread on pc and as a result
players are asking 343 to introduce a
cross-play toggle so that console
players can easily avoid those cheaters
according to the verge halo infinite
uses a quote server-side behavior-based
system to detect cheaters and remove
them from the game as opposed to making
use of a third-party software like easy
anti-cheat or battle eye some amount of
cheating is likely to exist in a
free-to-play multiplayer game like halo
infinite but it remains to be seen what
343 may do to prevent it developers
don't often reveal their anti-cheap
plans because doing so could give the
would-be cheaters hackers a tip-off
and while halo multiplayer is playable
early the campaign is not unless you're
one of these people breaking street date
cutscenes from halo infinite's campaign
have already begun leaking but now with
physical copies of the game beginning to
emerge in the wild it is a good time to
be extra careful when navigating the
internet to avoid spoilers
in other halo infinite news jerry hook
lead designer at 343 industries said on
twitter quote yes i am still playing
halo and feeling everyone's pain on
progression
halo infinite's progression system was
criticized almost immediately after the
game's multiplayer launched on november
15th in short players are upset about
how progression is tied to completing
challenges this system actively
encourages people to play the game to
complete challenges and not necessarily
to help the team or play in a more
natural way which according to players
leads to imbalance luckily 343 has made
changes already like the challenge deck
being updated to better serve players of
all skill levels and more robust updates
are coming later according to hook the
progression issues will be quote at the
top of my list to dig into with the team
when staffers return to the office this
week following a holiday break
another item on 343's list is a reported
balance issue within ranked matches halo
pro lethal took to twitter and said
quote would be nice if infinite ranked
matches were actually meant to match all
players of similar rank with each other
instead of doing dumb team balancing
can't even play with other people
without having people put in the game
who are deaf out of their territory no
fun for them either tbh in other words
please let us play with players of a
similar skill level a bronze ranked
player shouldn't be matched with or
against a gold rank player 343's
community manager replied to the tweet
and said quote we agree and the team is
looking into reports of matchups like
this we'll share more detailed updates
on this when we have them
so hit the comment section and let me
know if you're experiencing some of
these cheaters or weird team balancing
in ranked matches and what you want to
see from future halo infinite updates